hello and welcome to this video i'm
having the black pieces here in this
blitz game against do bits do [ __ ]
play them twice not won a game
maybe i get a dirty harry after d4
come on do it
he's reinventing chess now what about
rook g1
okay
uh-huh all of a sudden
you can you can play quickly right
so he went for the rosso limo instead
knight c4 okay
not sure where you're going with that
knight to c4
knight d2 i mean i was a freudian slip
thinking about a possible plan that
could be
no i have no clue what he's doing
what is he doing him f4 no that makes no
sense at all
very strange um we should be two maybe
is that the
move he's preparing
[Music]
i wonder if something like a5 takes b5
is an idea but
but that would only activate him right
yeah i don't know maybe he just wants to
move back and forth and win on time
this is a very common strategy and
you're trying to decipher what kind of
idea does he have
and at the end there's just no idea just
wants to
make random moves and win on time it's a
very popular strategy in fact
i'm not saying that this is the case he
has an idea i think but uh
sometimes i just spend too much time
trying to figure out okay
what on earth is that and there is just
no point
you should just make um yeah good moves
and
like reasonable moves and think uh
later right like f3 or what what's that
that is really not what is that
so i get to e3 and get to play f4 in
this position here
now i just have to stack on h2 and
deliver mate
sounds very simple
okay first of all i'm going to
make it more difficult for him to play
d4 ever
and then we'll see about potential uh
attacks it is really dangerous
what is he doing there i have no clue
anyway so
g5
and knight to d4 would be completely
devastating somehow but
hard to get maybe he wants to play
knight c4 i don't know
knight d1 ah that is the idea
okay
okay so this one
so my very strong bishop on d4 got
traded that is not
not very nice how do we
the knight should come to g3 yeah would
be really nice
like king f7 that is very slow
like knight g8 f6 and so on
still try okay
wow um
okay
g4 is hanging
this goes there i wonder if i can
actually do
that it looks a little bit
offside but
this is still going to be an attack
um the other one
i could have i mean i meant the other
rook here i could have just taken with
the h4 rook
but there could be cases like this where
or maybe night takes even yeah why not
knight takes
and now i need the queen clearly
but currently a7 is under fire
okay then he's got rook h3 let's take
this
you cannot play king f1 anyway
i need the queen
queen h7 is the idea
i'm not sure that that king e6 was the
best idea
now that the rook is away from the a
file
but what what what exactly can he do
here i mean king
queen h7 is going to be really dangerous
and that is a very nice way to put it
d4 queen h7 he has one check and that's
it like queen c4 king d7
and that's it okay so this is going to
at least win material
i'm going to take it
[Music]
it's just it's just better to
to grab the material
if i'm trying to find the maid that's
not there
given the the increment
there's no way in hell that he's
defending that so
here queen g one mate
it looks like curtains yeah
yeah i mean there's an amount of weird
moves that a position can take and he
played
many weird moves so
like this is fairly normal i think and
probably
a position where white has a small
advantage
which is kind of confirmed by the engine
i think from a structural point of view
um white should be um a little bit
better here
it's not much but then he started to
make a series of
really uh weird moves knight d2
was the first move that i didn't quite
get and he played knight e2
and yeah i felt i mean this is so slow
i should try something so f5 bishop b2
queen c7 and then that really strange
move f3 i mean what is that
why would you go f3 i don't know
okay the engine wants to play f4 g5 and
then attack
yeah maybe this is actually better it's
possible
as it is faster i mean i spent quite a
good amount of time with this
and ultimately the bishop got traded and
maybe that is indeed true
that f4 is good for g5
knight g6 and then throw the kitchen
sink
yeah it is it looks dangerous for sure
so we got this and i mean it looks
devastating i just need
like rook takes h2 queen h file made
i know that it takes a bit of time but
it's it's extremely strong once it hits
so we had this this g5 queen e2
oh yeah knight knight g6
okay i mean my position was not bad i'm
not i'm not saying that i just like
wonder okay so here actually white is
better with queen c3
why why
hmm okay i would
why can i not just play this
a direct problem and then knight f2
um i'm i'm sort of willing
to believe that white is better i'm just
a little bit shocked by the plus two
i wouldn't have thought that white could
be winning here
but maybe um it's just awful with the
rook on h6
it's really possible i don't get
anywhere in terms of an attack
and i cannot move those two pieces yeah
that is probably right
um i mean i i do know that the engine is
right
i mean it is rarely wrong in
any way and uh i'm just sometimes it
takes a moment to sink in like okay this
is really really terrible
he played this
and uh wow
i didn't think i was in such a a
problematic position
h3 knight g8 okay yeah queen c3 then
i totally did not see that move
queen c3 i don't know i had a total
blind spot i have no way of even
covering the pawn
remarkable he played all those instant
moves without any
any thought really now
um
it's still bad
it's still bad
d4 now it took a
series of a really bad bad decisions by
white to get me into a good position
probably here right okay the engine
finds some way to draw but then you have
to really start thinking at some point
and he just made
into in a super critical position made
instant moves
and here it is it is lost
king e6 is strongest move that's funny
and yeah you just you just win stuff
i did not realize that i was in so much
trouble
hmm yeah it's probably good to be an
optimist
okay guys thanks for watching